my parents are both conservative all
right and thank God you know it's funny
I have a very liberal personality you
know you take a personality test it can
tell you if you're liberal or
conservative luckily I spoke to my dad a
lot about these liberal ideas I would
find he was he would dispel all them my
sister not so lucky she's come out Pro
drag shows Pro how I'm like we have two
conservative parents they like
indoctrinate it's like all these women
that didn't have kids so they're trying
to indoctrinate yours
well that's what I I have people on
Twitter who don't love me because I talk
about these things and they'll be like
your kids are going to be weird I'm like
okay even if my kids are weird they're
not going to get off the school bus and
come tell me that they're switching
genders so